-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show."
I'm here with the one and only
Tariq Trotter from The Roots,
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, we're about to play
Charades,
but first, we're gonna need
some more players.
Joining my team,
she is currently starring
in Hulu's
"Only Murders in the Building."
Please welcome
Cara Delevingne, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi. How you doing?
Come here.
-Hi, my partner.
Come on, bud.
Joining Tariq's team,
you can watch him this Friday
in his brand-new
Netflix series, "Uncoupled."
Please welcome
Neil Patrick Harris!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Boom boom!
-He came to win.
What's up, man?
Good, good.
-All right.
We got this, we got this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, you all know
how to play Charades.
We're gonna do four rounds,
30 seconds on the clock
per round.
And then,
the fifth round is a showdown.
Both teams give the same clue
at the same time.
I will go first.
You guys can all
take your seats.
Neil, you're over there
with Tariq.
Cara, party, you're over here.
Let's go, bud.
All right, guys,
what number should I choose?
[ Audience shouting ]
I got a Southern --
I got a Southern three.
I got a "thray!"
-"Thray"!
All right, here goes three.
-Oh, my God.
-Okay.
Mm-hmm.
-[ Chuckles ]
-We got this, man.
-Yeah, I know, I know, I know.
Unagi.
-Ready for this?
Yeah, here we go.
-It's a song.
I got that part.
Three words.
First word.
Hot.
"Hot Girl Summer."
Hot -- two, second word.
In.
Hot in -- "Hot in Herre."
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's how you do it!
That's exactly right!
-Whoo! Hot in here.
-That's how you do it!
-Wow!
-Wow.
That's how you do it!
-It's weird
'cause it's cold in here.
-You're so happy
when she gets it right.
-That's how you do it!
♪ That is how you do it ♪
-Ah!
[ Laughs]
-All right.
Tariq, here you go.
-Ooh, this is scary.
-♪ So take off
all your clothes ♪
[ Audience shouting ]
-Stop pointing at 5.
They're saying other numbers.
You keep pointing at numbers --
No one's saying that number
at all.
-I'm taking 5, man.
-Oh, my God.
You are the worst.
-[ Laughs ]
-Ugh! Bad move.
-Oh no!
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-That's funny.
-All right, all right.
-It's a TV show.
-Mm-hmm.
Two words.
The first word...
is coyote.
-Be careful, buddy.
[ Laughter ]
Careful, buddy, careful.
-Yodel.
Don't m--
Hey, be careful, bud!
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, that --
-Cock-a-doodle-doo.
Like a bird in the sky.
Wolf.
Wolf -- moon --
Yeah, moon.
Moon raker.
Moon --
Second word.
Moonlighting.
Moon --
Moon fencing.
[ Buzzer ]
-Aah!
-I have no clue.
Do you know what it is?
-Moon fencing?
-"Moon Knight."
-All right, you're up.
-Okay. Okay, anybody,
numbers, numbers, numbers.
[ Audience shouting ]
Okay.
-10!
[ Laughter ]
-That's a good way to --
-10, thank you.
-They finally yelled 10.
Yeah, I love it.
-Okay.
Okay, sure.
All right.
Okay, okay, got this, got this.
-We got this.
-Wait. What is it?
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
-Okay.
Yep.
It's a movie.
One word.
Sounds like...
-[ Inhales ]
-...smoke.
Uh, vape, puff...
weed, joint...
Uh, no, go --
puff, smoke -- go back.
No, not smoke.
Inhaling.
Drugs, drugs.
No.
No inhale.
No -- no.
Nope.
"Nope"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Ding! ]
-"Nope" -- okay.
-♪ Nope, Nope, Nope,
Nope, Nope ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes, yes.
Rejoice.
-Nope to dope, man.
That was my campaign
in the '80s.
Say "nope" to dope.
-That was good.
-All right.
Now the pressure's on.
-Neil, you got this.
-What number should I do?
[ Audience shouting ]
-I'm gonna go with number 1.
Because we need
at least this many points.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
Um...
Okay.
-Wow.
-It's a song.
Two words.
Second word -- okay, first word.
First word, two letters.
-Mnh-mnh.
-Short.
First word, short.
It.
[ Laughter ]
Prisoner.
Prisoner of prison.
Jail.
No.
Okay.
Jail box.
Jail -- jailbird.
Jail cell.
Jail -- free -- free as a bird.
Jail free.
Free --
[ Laughter ]
Jail dance.
Jail.
-Elvis.
-Oh, uh, uh, "Jailhouse Blues."
[ Buzzer ]
-Jailhouse Rock, Jailhouse Rock!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Jailhouse blues!
[ Laughs ]
The jailhouse blues.
-I said rock.
-I got it, I got it.
I got it right.
-I knew he wouldn't get it
even if you said, "Elvis."
He's like,
"Uh, jailhouse blues?
I don't know.
Something like that."
Dude, that was
great right there.
-That was good.
-All right, that was great.
You know how to play.
All right, now here's the deal.
This is the last round here.
Whoever wins this,
it's for 10,000 points.
-Oh, wow.
-Whoever wins this
wins the whole game.
It's a lot of points.
-So we do it together?
-Yeah, so each team chooses
who -- who gives the clues.
-Okay.
-So, yeah, I'm gonna say Cara.
-I was pretty bad.
-I think
you're great at giving clues.
Cara.
Neil versus Cara?
And then you --
-What do we do?
We both simultaneously...
-Read the same clue.
-We act it out simultaneously?
-Yes.
-Fun, fun.
-Which one are we going for?
Say it after three.
1, 2, 3 --
-4.
-Wow!
They both said 4.
-Like magic.
All right.
-Okay, but wait.
-Don't look, don't look.
-How does it work?
-Jailhouse blues.
-Shut up.
Geez, dude.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow. Geez Louise.
Wow.
-That's really unfair.
-I didn't look.
-This is very unfair.
-So, wait, am I doing it...?
-Yes.
-Wait, wait, wait.
Can we just think about it
for a second?
-[ Laughs ]
Cara, we have this, don't --
There's no pressure.
-I don't know, man.
-It's all right.
I'm not looking.
You can't turn around
because then I can see it.
I don't want to see it.
-Ah.
So...
-All right. We got this.
-Okay.
-We have it.
-Okay, no wait, wait!
-TV show.
Three words.
-Three words.
-Second word.
Short, little.
"Big little lies."
-No, no, no!
No wait.
Wait, it was like --
"Pretty Little Liars!"
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Whoo!
-Wow, wow, wow!
-Wow!
-That was so fast.
I'm so sorry.
-My thanks to Cara Delevingne!
-Wow!
-Neil Patrick Harris!
-That was so fast!
-Tariq Trotter.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We are talking to Neil
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
"Jailhouse blues!"
♪♪